HAVE TODAY.
>> JOHN, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND YOUR
INSIGHT TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR PROTECTING THE
YOUTH.
ONE PARENT.
BEING AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS SHE
CONFRONTED THE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD AND ITS RESPONSE ENDED UP
PROVING HER POINT.
HERE IS AN EXCERPT AND I'M GOIN
TO HAVE TO TRY TO BE HERE.
EXCITED NOW HE PUSHED INTO HER.
AS SHE SQUEEZED HER EYES AND
TIGHTLY AS SHE COULD, HER TONGU
CIRCLED HER LIPS.
HE PUSHED HARDER, HIS BREATH
HEAVY AND LABORED, SHE SCRATCHE
HIS BACK AND HE CRIED OUT GREAT
SHE BIT HIS EAR AND PULLED HIS
HAIR, THERE IS A LOT MORE TO IT.
50 SHADES OF GRAY AND CSST.
>> EXCUSE ME CAN WE HAVE
CHILDREN AT HOME.
IT'S REALLY NOT APPROPRIATE.
>> DON'T YOU FIND THE IRONY IN
THAT?
YOU ARE EXACTLY SAYING EXACTLY
WHAT I'M TELLING YOU.
TRENDING ONE
>> Laura: JOINING IS NOW IS
MICHELLE BROWN PARADIGM GUESSIN
THEY DIDN'T SEE THE IRONY.
>> NO.
NO.
AND IRONY IS EVEN MORE SO IS
THAT I'M IN CHEROKEE COUNTY
GEORGIA AND WE ARE ONE OF THE
TOP REPUBLICAN COUNTIES IN THE
STATE FOR IT LET ME START BY
SAYING I LOVE MY COUNTY.
I LIVE WHERE I LIVE.
I LOVE BEING IN A CONSERVATIVE
TOWN.
I LOVE MY SCHOOL, THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM, OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS I'VE NOTICED SINCE SLOWLY
BUT SURELY IT STARTED TO
BECOMING A WEEK IN TO SEE SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE IN THE
CURRICULUM.
I NOTICED LAST SUMMER THERE WER
LOTS OF NEW STORIES AND PARENTS
COMING UP AND TALKING ABOUT
BOOKS AND IT WAS BECOMING
ALARMING.
THANK GOODNESS I LIVE IN
CONSERVATIVE CHEROKEE COUNTY IN
THEN COME THIS FALL AT THE BOAR
MEETING I SAW A PARENT GET UP
AND PEAKED ABOUT ONE OF THE
BOOKS VERY TINTED THE NEXT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING ANOTHER
PARENT GOT UP AND SPOKE ABOUT
ONE OF THE BOOKS.
>> IN STATEMENT TO FOX, THE
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SAID THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE, YOU DO NOT HAVE STUDENTS
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND HAD
BEEN REPEATEDLY ADVISED THAT YO
COULD FILE A CHALLENGE TO REMOV
THE BOOK, BUT YOU HAVE NOT DONE
SO.
WILL, YOU DON'T HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT.
>> WE DID.
HOWEVER, SO I AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OUR GROUP.
OUR GROUP AS A VARIETY OF WHERE
A SMALL GROUP.
WE ARE UNDERGROUND IF YOU WILL
GRASSROOTS, AND WE HAVE ABOUT 10
-12 OF US AND THERE ARE
PARENTS, GRANDPARENTS, I HAVE
ELEMENTARY, MIDDLE SCHOOL, HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WITHIN CSST.
WE STARTED BECAUSE WE WANTED TO
HELP WE WANTED TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE WHICH IS THE SAVE SAVE
LIBRARY BILL.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF I GAVE YOU,
EXCUSE ME, IF I GAVE A CHILD ON
OF THESE BOOKS, I WOULD GO TO
JAIL.
BUT THEY CAN GET IT IN OUR
SCHOOL LIBRARIES.
AND IT'S NOT OKAY.
>> AT THE LEFT IS LIKE YOUR BOO
MANNER.
YOU JUST WANT TO BAN BOOKS, SO
YOU'RE A BOOK MANNER AND THEY
THINK YOU'RE A TROUBLEMAKER.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
SCHOOL CHAIR BOARD CALLED IT,
SHE JUST PUT OUT AN ARTICLE
TODAY CALLING IT THE BAND BOOK
LIST AND THAT IS WHAT LIBERALS
SAY.
SO I'M KIND OF QUESTIONING,
SHOULDN'T HAVE AN APPROVED LIST?
SHOULDN'T WE HAVE BOOKS THAT AR
DEEMED APPROPRIATE TO